at CSUN and in other critical operations
in Southeast Asia free world forces have
been aided by a knowledge of the enemy's
location and movement much of this
battlefield intelligence has been
developed by the employment of an
integrated detection surveillance system
which performs day and night under all
weather conditions this system has
enabled our forces to direct timely
copper measures against concentrations
of enemy troops and supplies
this surveillance system is based on the
concept of utilizing an electronic
sensing or eavesdropping device which
can be monitored from a remote location
we are in effect bugging the battlefield
the communist aggression against South
Vietnam has been supported by an
overland flow of men and supplies from
North Vietnam by way of several
infiltration routes hundreds of gasoline
and diesel cargo trucks operate on a
complex network of roads in communist
controlled areas the dense jungle canopy
overhead the complex network of roads
trails and footpaths the constantly
changing weather conditions and the
rugged terrain make the detection of
this infiltrating traffic difficult to
assist in solving the problem of
reducing infiltration of enemy personnel
and supplies into South Vietnam the
Department of Defense initiated a
program to develop an anti in filtration
system for gathering intelligence and by
its use impeding these movements it is
based on implanting patterns of sensing
devices which electronically detect
earth vibrations or sounds caused by
moving vehicles or troops these sensors
are monitored by ground troops and
airborne personnel in practice both air
and ground support often are used in the
same military operations but for the
moment let's consider the two means of
support separately first the system when
supported by air this system is used
primarily in inaccessible areas as an
enemy vehicle or troop detachment moves
along a route which is under
surveillance ground vibrations or sounds
activate one sensor after another
these sensors transmit identity codes
and sometimes actual sounds of movement
by self-contained radio transmitters to
special manned or unmanned aircraft
which orbit the sensor fields monitoring
the sensor transmissions automatic relay
equipment aboard the aircraft relays the
sensor signals to an infiltration
surveillance center their Center
personnel analyze these activated
sensors then in correlation with other
intelligence determined the gross size
and types of targets with the direction
and rate of movement
once identified targets are reported to
the airborne command and control center
and two task force strike operations
which assigns attack aircraft for a
strike
strike reports are analyzed by the
infiltration surveillance center for
effectiveness and for future planning
another method of utilizing the system
is by hand and placing the sensors in
areas accessible to ground troops when
ground vibrations or sounds activate
sensors the transmitted signals are
monitored at ground sites by personnel
using portable readout devices and relay
were required when targets are
identified and their movements plotted a
request is made for fire support
air support also can be directed to
attack the target
let's look at several of the sensors
which have been developed for this
program one type is the seismic sensor
which when activated by ground
vibrations caused by the passage of
vehicles or personnel transmits an
identification code by radio waves to a
monitor this for example is an air
delivered seismic intrusion detectors or
add Sid this detector although designed
originally for air delivery by fighter
aircraft or helicopters can be emplaced
also by hand it is a camouflaged seismic
sensor which when activated by ground
vibrations periodically transmits a tone
identification as long as the sensor is
activated this one is the fighter air
delivered seismic intrusion detector or
fab Sid it is a seismic sensor for
detection of personnel and vehicles it
is capable of responding to commands
originating from the infiltration
surveillance centre or the monitoring
aircraft the commands can cause the
sensor either to transmit activations
immediately store them for later recall
or reply to a status check it is
designed to fit in high-speed dispensers
the helicopter seismic intrusion
detector or hello Sid is helicopter
deployed it can be launched by a retro
firing dispenser or by hand and what
emplaced is capable of responding to
commands similar to the fad FID
the ground and placed seismic intrusion
detector orgy Sid is essentially an air
delivered detector which has been
redesigned for hand emplacement it is
smaller in volume and weight than the
add Sid but has improved performance
characteristics the absurd components
have also been redesigned for delivery
by 81 millimeter mortar this is the
mortar delivered sensor or mods
investigations are underway to develop a
sensor to be delivered by light and
medium artillery another example is the
hand and placed seismic intrusion
detector or hand Sid it contains an
internal geophone to detect seismic
activity in addition it has a connection
to permit the use of external detectors
one such connector is this magnetic
intrusion device Magadh designed to
detect the passage of ferromagnetic
material such as a rifle or truck
a later version the mini Sid retains the
same capabilities as the hand Sid but
with one half the weight
the other major type of sensor is the
acoustic detector which when activated
by sounds not only transmits by radio
and identification code but also
retransmits such sounds as the noise of
passing vehicles and munitions
detonating and sometimes the actual
voices of enemy soldiers talking nearby
passing and open watching doc one
example is this acoustic sensor called
an aqua boy used to detect sounds of
personnel and vehicles it can be
delivered by air or hand and placed when
air deployed a camouflaged parachute
guides the descent of the sensor it is
designed to catch in the jungle canopy
suspending the aquaboy above the ground
to permit better sounds pickup and to
make it more difficult to detect
another version is the spike boy an
acoustic sensor with a spike nose
permitting implant in the ground these
items can be hand or air and placed
other types of sensors incorporate
combinations of sensing elements
theocracy is a seismic sensing device
with optional acoustic listening on
command all sensors which are not
intended for recovery have provisions
for end-of-life and or anti-tamper
destruct packages to prevent recovery by
the enemy specialized air and placed
munitions such as the small camouflaged
mines have been developed to provide
protection for sensors they inhibit
personnel movement off trails deter
construction of new trails and
discouraged searching for sensors
additionally some sensors are booby trap
other types of munitions are used along
truck routes to immobilize truck convoys
and to impede accompanying dismounted
troops as with the sensors munitions
have a predetermined end of life
this is accomplished either by self
sterilization or self destruct
to produce useful intelligence signals
transmitted from sensors must be
monitored and evaluated this aircraft is
used in the air supported system as an
airborne radio relay station to
retransmit sensor signals to the
infiltration surveillance center
a supervisors position has facilities
for monitoring all channels on which
sensor signals are being retransmitted
selected signals can be recorded for
later analysis
for operator positions provide a backup
capability to support to the ground
station permitting operators onboard the
aircraft to monitor and analyze sensor
information the infiltration
surveillance Center provides the central
point for planning monitoring and
managing the air supported system
information is maintained here on the
location and identification of all
sensors and minefields all sensor
signals are directed to a digital data
computer which immediately prints out a
report of sensor activation
at audio monitoring positions operators
analyze actual sounds of enemy vehicles
and personnel which have been
transmitted by acoustic sensors and
present a visual report on each signal
target assessment officers plot
locations of the sensors being activated
and determine the direction and rate of
movement of an enemy column as well as
its gross type and size this information
is correlated with weather reports and
other intelligence information such as
known locations of rest areas and truck
parks to determine targets for strike
action
when the surveillance system is ground
supported monitoring normally is much
simpler
each monitoring site often is
responsible for an area within mortar or
artillery range and with sensors located
in the general area of the monitor
location a portable readout device
called a porta tail as a self-contained
very high frequency FM receiver a
display unit incorporating telltale
lights and is battery-powered the Porter
tail registers identity codes from
activated seismic and acoustic sensors
and can receive actual sounds of enemy
activity when used in conjunction with
acoustic sensors this device can be
mounted and operated in a vehicle
aircraft or small patrol craft using the
carrying vehicles electric power or the
self-contained battery let's see how
both air and ground supported systems
are used in a typical situation for air
supported operations intelligence
personnel at the infiltration
surveillance center keep a constant
watch over enemy activity they plan the
most lucrative locations for implanting
of sensors and associated minefields
when actual locations have been selected
a request for aerial emplacement is made
aircraft take off to deliver the sensors
to the selected locations
after the sensors have been implanted
and are in operation actual sensor
locations are plotted from photographs
taken during the drop
this information is fed into the digital
data computer then the air supported
system is ready for an interdiction
operation a North Vietnamese replacement
unit is advancing southward
it's dismounted troops infiltrating by a
rather direct route into South Vietnam
as its supply convoys move down through
another route
activations from the convoy are picked
up by the seismic sensors
these activations are transmitted to the
airborne relay platform maintaining its
daily schedule in orbit 40 kilometers
from the sensors
other sensors are activated as the
convoy proceeds on route
the detections can be passed verbally to
an appropriate fire direction center or
automatically relayed to the ISC for
computer print every five minutes the
computer prints out an updated report
as the enemy convoy passes each acoustic
sensor an audio operator analyzes the
sounds of the truck engines to provide
confirmation and supplementary
information about the type and number of
vehicles output of the computer is
rushed to the target assessment officer
assigned to the particular area sequence
one-niner appears to be moving at a
fairly continuous rate what do you make
of it
about 18 klicks an hour this computer
report serves to confirm point-to-point
movement time direction and apparent
size of infiltrating forces
target information is passed to
operations after consideration of
whether other air activities in the area
of interest availability of forward air
controllers and strike aircraft strike
requests are forwarded to the airborne
command and control center Red Dog this
is brown bear request air strike over
area of sensors 2020 whenever practical
targets are confirmed by visual
observation by forward air controllers
target confirmation is relayed to task
force operations either direct or by
communications relay through the
airborne command and control center
when a decision is made by a
command-and-control facility to divert
airborne aircraft the ABC CC establishes
radio contact with the tactical fighters
and relays all necessary target
information type and size of target
location direction of movement and so
forth the designated Fighter Wing is
directed to scramble alert aircraft when
an airborne flight is not available for
diversion to strike the target
strike reports are analyzed at the
infiltration surveillance center as part
of a continuing evaluation of system
effectiveness and to aid in future
planning
in a typical ground operation
intelligence reports have indicated the
approach of dismounted troops of the
North Vietnamese replacement unit toward
free world for positions in South
Vietnam positions for our infantry and
direct support weapons are chosen to
take maximum advantage of the terrain
plans are made to implant sensors at
probable avenues of approach within
range of direct support weapons and
within line of sight of monitor sights
both seismic and acoustic sensors are
emplaced by hand in the more accessible
areas by aircraft in the less accessible
areas with the sensors and placed
according to plan and their locations
accurately known personnel at each
ground monitor site can begin operations
we're all set at Bravo 1/7 Roger
that's a 13 activated sector it's 0 9 to
3 Zulu
let's see if they stay on the trail
here 10 to 14 up so that's 0 9 to 6 over
I'll make it 3 minutes tell me when you
stop getting activations on 14
the officer determines from the time
elapsing between sensor activation the
pattern and speed of movement of the
infiltrating troops from the length of
time which each sensor is activated he
estimates the probable number of troops
so 215 is upset right on schedule
they're maintaining their same rate and
staying on the trail
let's get the fire Direction center on
this is Bravo one seven I have a target
identified
charlie is moving southeast down the
trail into our position request
pre-planned fire at position alpha
Charlie on my mark
standby ready
ready mark
fire
with the aid of sensors charlie's
penetration has been detected and
impeded aerial reconnaissance detects no
further sign of enemy movement in the
area sensors can be used in many ground
applications monitoring of landing zones
base perimeter defense combat sweep
operations anti ambushed convoy
protection route surveillance
surveillance of enemy base camps
offensive ambushes and targeting of
enemy troop concentrations
larger more complex sensor arrays can be
monitored at major command data
gathering points an aircraft is used as
an airborne relay platform
sensor activations are relayed by the
aircraft to a mobile surveillance Center
which is co-located with the fire
support Coordination Center and the
direct air support center
this mobile surveillance center provides
timely information of sensor activations
to the command data gathering point
other support is also available this
gunship contains a porter tail which is
monitoring ground and placed sensors in
an area which is inaccessible to
artillery fire an enemy reinforcements
column is bringing up you Nisshin
navigator to pilot you'll have a target
on center 2 3 at 12 minutes past the
hour
Roger take up a heading of 145 degrees
your eta is 1 1
gun pop the elusive enemy has been
located stopped and apparently badly
mauled without the effectiveness of the
integrated infiltration detection system
he might have slipped by our defense
this system is presently in use
throughout Vietnam in riverine Delta
operations as a defense against
waterborne interdiction and for
protection of cities further it has been
evaluated for usin amphibious assaults
and presently is limited in its use only
by the imagination of the user
future developments are aimed toward
more and improved instrumentation
meantime all reports indicate that
bugging the battlefield pays off